hi me my friends from Germany we would
like to know how your invention will
change the current state of the art and
the these fields of appliance because
right now we use it in computers its
revenue and we would like to know which
other fields of application you have in
mind using your yeah invention thank you
yeah so actually the discovery of the
gia ma was the first step in a new fear
of his service called spintronics has
been Tony include many other effects
also exploiting the spinning of the
electrons and so many other interesting
affected be found for example we are
walking now on him named Philip we surf
is called spin class fare and were
walking merely on research leading to
application in telecommunication a new
generation of oscillator for the
emission of reception of hydro waves so
this is nothing to see with the with the
our disc and the gmr and we are also
working on cowboy bends material are
carbon nanotubes and graphene for a for
application certainly at long term for
the perspective of Beyonce most after
the electronic of silicon the electronic
voice Umi conductor follows what is
called moose low a policy reduction of
the size of the components but one knows
that this this low will and after maybe
now 10 years and so this is a a great
problem an important problem for
electronics what will be after and so
this is no other beyond CMOS problem
what we look after the
electronic on silicon called CMOS
electronics and so people are thinking
about new type of technology to heal the
CMOS electronics and silicon electronics
and this spintronics see one of the way
and in particular spinto agrees
carbon-based materials like graphene or
carbon nanotubes